so since lately I seem to be according
severe reactions from people why don't I
go ahead and continue that trend and why
don't we take a minute to talk about
Wonder Woman and the importance of
proportional representation it's been
interesting for me to watch the ongoing
conversation about Wonder Woman as both
a character and as a film in which that
character is portrayed now it's
interesting to me because obviously at
this point we know the critical reaction
it was overwhelmingly positive we also
know the box office which has had
amazing legs both of these are success
stories when we dive into people's
reactions things start to get a little
bit more mixed there are certainly
plenty of people who are immediate to
embrace this film and it is by my
estimation a good film in fact a very
good film and there have been lots of
people who embrace it and clutch it and
cling to their art and go finally a
woman superhero this is the next coming
this is amazing and I'm very happy for
those people
unfortunately what I've also seen happen
is people who do not feel that the
character is quite as well represented
or that the film is quite as good have
been jumped on in weird ways now some of
this is anecdotal I haven't dealt with a
ton of it myself but I've known more
than a couple of people and have
encountered more as within podcasts
fears that I listen to as people relay
their own experiences with this movie
and their feelings about it
that when they bring up concerns that
they have it's it becomes a very weird
conversation that they have with people
who basically are like don't point out
the flaws in this and then there is the
other side of that coin which is P which
are people who seem to really want to
tear this film down because Wonder Woman
is not feminist enough in the movie or
because of her actions are driving a
masculine narrative because ultimately
she solves most of her problems by
punching
now I don't actually want to have the
conversation to hear right now as to
whether Diana is portrayed as being too
feminist not feminist enough is it
better that the film sort of fits the
standard super-hearing there and if so
that women can finally have
representation within those narratives
that have been existing for other they'd
been excluded from would it have been
better if she had had a story that was
more unique to a female perspective and
that it wouldn't have been so easy to
just slot a male hero in in terms of the
kinds of actions that she take should it
should it have been made more uniquely
feminine in its approach to both the
film and to her as a character would
that have been better did the film
transpose the difference was that to the
detriment of the film that it did these
are all questions worth discussing but I
don't want to discuss them here because
I don't think any of them would be
getting asked if proportional
representation of women in film and
superhero films specifically in this
case was not a problem and by
proportional representation
I mean 50% over 50% statistically of the
population of the planet that we all
live on our women Wonder Woman is the
first female lead superhero movie since
2005 when Elektra came out between the
release of Elektra and the release of
Wonder Woman there were 53 comic book
based superhero movies released to
theaters which either starred men or
featured teams overwhelmingly made up of
men to not have had a single movie in 12
years and 53 other films that's weird
and the thing is that kind of creates
the problem and the weird conversation
that is happening around Wonder Woman as
a result because so much gets put on
this film this thing was carrying a
crazy amount of weight that has no
business being put on one film it was
effectively carrying 53 movies of weight
on till 1
film because I think it was a very valid
concern that if Wonder Woman had tanked
it might have killed females led
superhero movies again because they've
been killed previously but that's
ridiculous how can just one bad film of
a specific strength of superhero lead to
digits not happening for over a decade
because there's not enough of them
the fewer that there are the more
important each individual one becomes
it's basic physics it's the district
it's the distribution of weight it's the
principle that a bed of nails works on
the more points of contact that there
are the less pressure there is on each
individual one if there is only one
point of contact all of the pressure is
on that one point of contact and in this
case if I were to step out of the
metaphor the pressure in this case is
the pressure to be good now the pressure
on all of those other 53 male lead films
was all fairly low some were great some
were terrible but they didn't have to be
good any one of those could fail and the
genre wasn't something going to go away
because there was plenty of other points
of contact there was plenty of weight to
distribute the weight of and the
importance of this genre across all
these films so one could fail HEC 10
could fail it wasn't going to kill the
genre but when you narrow it down to the
more specific sub-genre of female led
superheroes it's just Wonder Woman and
if that had failed he could have killed
it and we'd seen that happen before and
if you want to even take it out of the
gender context you go back to Batman or
Robin which many people blamed for
killing superhero movies at the time and
you know there were some that were made
within a few years of it but really kind
of effectively as far as big-budget
superhero movies when it did kill it but
the reason that it was able to kill it
if there was not nearly as many
superhero movies coming out at that time
Batman pretty much was the stand
Bearer because other superhero movies
either hadn't really gotten off the
ground yet or hadn't connected and so
when the franchise carrying the weight
of the superhero genre failed that was
kind of it for a bit but at this point
we don't need that anymore even Batman
which I would say is still the premier
franchise of super in among superheroes
Batman the new Batman film could be
awful I hope it's not but it could be
superheroes aren't going to go anywhere
in terms of their presence in film
because there's so many of them so when
I say proportional representation if the
number of female led superheroes was
even close to the proportion of women in
the perspective audience then we
wouldn't have to worry whether or not
one film like Wonder Woman manages to be
all things all people manages to be
exciting enough manages to be feminist
that we wouldn't have to worry about
that because if we had more women
superheroes then we could have one that
is very much a strongly feminist
character we could have one that is more
acting masculine and sort of playing in
the boys club kind of thing we could
have one that tackles things from a more
uniquely female perspective as opposed
to just solving all the problems with
punching we could have a diversity of it
if there was just more places to do it
the other thing that's worth bringing up
is how weird again the conversation got
about Black Widow in age of Ultron and
the thing that happened with a storyline
there and again I don't really want to
get into whether or not what was done
specifically in terms of revealing that
she wasn't able to have kids and the
impact that had on her as a character I
don't necessarily want to get into
whether or not that was a good thing or
not but the conversation that happened
that basically said ah see they reduced
her her value to the fact that she can't
be a mother therefore she thinks she's a
mobster bah sexism and again I don't
want to say whether or not that is
sexist but I don't think it's a
conversation that would have
had to happen if she wasn't literally
the girl of the marvel and see you if
there were more then she would be
allowed that space to explore the idea
of how having the choice to ever become
a mother taken away from her impacts her
as a character without having to bring
in all this meta baggage but she stuck
with the baggage because she's kind of
it yes we've got Scarlet Witch now we'll
get Captain Marvel but even Marvel which
is you know I'm I praise Marvel a lot I
get labeled a Marvel Sam boy often
they've been way too slow to get on this
bandwagon and it's and actually I would
say diversity across the board they're
finally doing better and with some of
the softer level but it's still it's
still not proportional representation
and it's especially frustrating with
comic books whether it's DC or marvel
because you look at the actual cast of
the comics there is a much better degree
of representation especially if you're
talking about women in the comic books
than the movies indicate so if we could
just get more examples honestly good or
bad if we just had more there'd be less
pressure on each one and we could stop
having this thing where a female
character is put front and center and is
getting taken down by people saying we
need more strong women but then they
have go then they go but not that if
there were more options there would be
one that could meet their standard but
we wouldn't also lose whatever it was
this one that they thought wasn't good
enough we could have a buffet of choice
we could have the kind of diversity that
we get in our male characters where some
are Paragons like Captain America some
are deeply troubled and compromised like
Iron Man we don't have that diversity of
female characters and there's no reason
that we shouldn't I think I'm going to
close by saying something that I read
Sigourney Weaver said now unfortunately
I am slightly too lazy to look up the
exact quote but what she said when she
was asked about female representation in
films she basically made a plea to
screenwriters and she said look half the
population is female so if you write a
script and half of the characters aren't
female
there isn't a story-based reason for
that to be the case please fix it and
yeah that's pretty much where I land and
that's not saying you can never make a
story that's about men or that is
predominantly a male story of course you
can you absolutely can I would in fact
make the argument that there are films
that would be better if they had the
female characters removed predator comes
to mind but unless that is specifically
what you're doing and if you want to do
that that's fine that's a perfectly
valid thing to do but if that's not what
you're doing if you're just trying to
tell a story and it's not a my own story
then it should be half women the
character should we have women
proportionally it just should and
there's no reason why it can't be and if
we could get there then these weird
weird bizarre reactions to things like
Wonder Woman or possibly even the
casting of the doctor might not have to
happen at all we wouldn't have to all be
jumping on these few examples because
there'd be plenty of others that we
could turn to so those are my thoughts
on proportional representation filtered
through the idea of Wonder Woman and the
place of female superheroes in film so
um what are your thoughts on all this
whatever they are if you could keep them
respectful I greatly appreciate it I
know I've been coordinating more I don't
want to say controversial but I guess
heated topics lately but part of the
reason is I like seeing well-thought-out
responses may even ones that disagree
with me I love having those
conversations are you apply to some of
the comments so if you can keep
respectful by all means disagree with me
if you want to praise me that works too
but whatever your thoughts are drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about it don't forget to like
subscribe check me out on Twitter at
council of geeks give a listen to the
council of geeks podcast available on
iTunes and stitcher and until next time
this council is adjourned
[Applause]
[Applause]